youtube
コメントなんていうのがありますよね見ますたまに
規範されてたらどうですよそれが悲しいうんそういうことだ
いやそういうことが言いたいわけじゃなくてどうだったと youtube て
コメント欄ってとこがあってそこでこういろんな人があの戦闘お弁当意見と金子
楽しかったというわけなんですけどもうコメントなんてこの一番上にくるのがよく見
られるじゃんやってどういう順番になってるか知ってるコメントで
んでではないよ振ったずんじゃなくてコメントの評価が高い順というか
a チャンソンのみられたり硬派リアクションされているコメントが一番上に来てるん
ですよ一番ホットな奴が今一番上に来ているわけでございますで今回はどーんと一番上
のコメントはなんぞなフェンスクーンまあ僕ぐらいんの音宇宙パティなるとちょっと
コメント矩行
なんかな
であるわけですアルゴリズムがあってだって僕が使ってるわけですのアルゴリズムも
こういう動画には恋来みたく
どういうコメントがこんな形になるかと結構はくるんですよね今回は的に動画は僕の
どんどんドライバー選んでもらってその動画の一番上のポイント何か僕がもう一字一句
間違えてに当てます
完璧に
1実家不利なの i 実行を止めように音声があってたんですよねだったニュアンスを
当てます
ラテれるまで終われません
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
すごい2160この磁石ボールで何ができるのか
磁石ボール2160コカまあ率直な僕で喧嘩言いますと
もったいないとかが多い気がするんだ何だろうなぁ
なんだと思っ
この後何に使う
[音楽]
このコメントに good 詐取と明日告白される果たして正解は
うん俺じゃねえ京都署名が価格を支えたんだけどちょっとこれ
そっか瀬文の顔でもあるのか常にその次のコメントはひとりかくれんぼ動画見た後怖く
なって逃げてきた
関係ねーな分きれぬ検証政治
男性何人で重なるジャンプ買わせるのかああ
アロレ難しいなぁジャンプを破ってるんでしょたしか
いやーこれ難しいでジャンプもったいない
ちゃんともったいないかジャンプ以上に出るとグッドボタンさあ認め予想
[音楽]
ばた本なんだよねアンディが
v ジャンプ欲しいるところがはを真空状態にしてみたぁー
どっちかクリア皿やめよこれちょっと
やヴァイスビアボードに雪ですよねこれがはってどこで買えるの
ソースが物議また俺の可能性もあるから僕の可動性も踏まえと言うで何て言ってだけ
このコメント覚えてるんだよなぁ髪型変とか
ああ
ああああああああああっ今入っん
苦節だけ
また本に自分がやばいよね最近の動画に植栽チューブ動画23歳男性初めての
コンタクトレンズ
これはないが割と読みやすい気もしますなーさー
木した青わかった裏分かってる分かったメガネのはじめも月
ねコンタクトをつけてる人グッドボタン
このほども絶対コレでしょ
わー
俺しかいないじゃこんばんはうわけじゃねーぞまずで
ああ
んじゃなかったねお宿ねこれだけ
いや惜しかったし彼と僕を除けばあってましたね健康肌で線
まとめても行ったかロマンチックなのか家事
ああなるほどいやーこれこそ最近の入りでこれはこのコメントに good シェルター
した顧客される今入っ
はっはっはちょっとセンサーでこれはねー
これ前に辞めたっていう通気検査したら結果がよろしくなかったために辞めたから
約なるんじゃねああああ
なんかまた1年を貸し切りしたでみたいああ
お菓子禁止した意味はたまたそういうでございんだよな
始めちょっと太ったみたいいけばはいさー
んだにゃーそっちじゃあ少し禁止した意味
はたまたそういうで事言ってるなう
大量抜くコーラに乗れば俺も受けるきますこれこそたぶんね最近れるぞ
ててあの流行りが来るかなーあれでこのコメントに good 端を奏した朝顧客のれ
ないと思った
ブーブーためてる人なるほどね決まっはい
私は発明を好きな16歳の女の子ですはじめあなたは韓国でもとても有名な
youtube スターです私は日本のお菓子も好きで韓国と日本が仲良く過ごしたら
いいと思いますありがとうございます
どんな変化気はあるか嬉しいけど変化球だね30日に一人で部屋にいたら誰か来て
くれる
もう誕生日おめでとうでしょおめでとう俺えっめっちゃ素敵
てないからまた聞いてまずは敵がないんだ
その可能性はある1まあそういう競争きます
あっはターンを5-1よし俺の誕生日だよ
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ
やばいぞ育って予想されては野外編機で